tenemos un círculo por aquí y la primera
pregunta que podemos hacernos es cuáles
son las coordenadas del centro de este
círculo entonces para que quede más
claro cuáles son y cuál es el centro de
este círculo lo voy a remarcar
justamente a aquí muy bien entonces aquí
tenemos la digamos el centro de nuestro
círculo verdad entonces podríamos
escribir de hecho cuáles son sus
coordenadas verdad aquí tenemos su
coordenada en la digamos en el eje
horizontal es menos cuatro verdades
menos cuatro y su coordenada en el eje
vertical es menos 7 así que este centro
de nuestra circunferencia tiene
coordenadas menos cuatro coma menos
siete muy bien entonces digamos también
que alguien nos garantiza que hay un
punto que se encuentra sobre la
circunferencia y ese punto digamos es
este que tenemos aquí quizás voy a
hacerlo con otro color más claro
digamos este punto que tenemos aquí que
es el menos 5,9 entonces el punto menos
menos 9 está sobre sobre la
circunferencia sobre sobre el círculo
vamos a escribirlo mejoras y sobre él
círculo bien ahí lo tenemos entonces con
base en esto la pregunta ahora es
podríamos calcular el radio de esta
circunferencia y pues en realidad
recordemos que el rail el radio es la
distancia entre el centro y cualquier
punto de esta circunferencia verdad en
particular este que alguien nos
garantizó que está sobre el círculo
verdad de hecho recordemos cuál es la
definición del círculo y y en realidad
excepto el conjunto de todos esos puntos
que distan lo mismo de un punto fijo que
en este caso es el centro verdad
entonces técnicamente lo único que
tenemos que hacer es calcular la
distancia de este punto a este otro
punto muy bien entonces esta es la
distancia que queremos calcular y que
vamos a llamar de y para poder hacerlo
vamos a tener que recurrir a nuestro
viejo amigo el teorema de pitágoras
verdad para poder esencialmente calcular
la distancia entre 2
puntos muy bien entonces lo que tenemos
que calcular es por ejemplo la distancia
al cuadrado y después obtendremos quien
es la distancia entonces para calcular
esta distancia podemos construir un
triángulo rectángulo verdad que
esencialmente será de la siguiente forma
vamos a tener un cambio en x aquí va a
estar nuestro cambio en x y vamos a
tener una altura esta altura de aquí que
va a ser nuestro cambio en g
muy bien entonces como calculamos todo
esto bueno en principio gracias al
teorema de pitágoras tendremos que la
distancia al cuadrado será la suma de
los cuadrados de los catetos en este
caso un cateto es delta x es decir el
cambio en x al cuadrado
el otro cateto que es el cambio en al
cuadrado muy bien entonces vamos a ver
quién sería el cambio en x bueno el
cambio en x esencialmente es x final - x
inicial verdad y en realidad no importa
cuál consideremos como el inicial y el
final siempre y cuando seamos
consistentes verdad entonces por ejemplo
digamos que este es el punto final
verdad entonces tendremos la coordenada
menos 5 tendremos menos 5 será x final
menos el x inicial que es menos 4 verdad
entonces menos 5 - menos 4 es menos 5
más 4 y eso es menos 1 y tiene sentido
verdad nos estamos moviendo 1 pero hacia
atrás verdad entonces ahí tenemos quien
es nuestro cambio en x y ahora vamos a
calcular quién es nuestro cambio en ye y
otra vez será nuestra final que será
menos 9 menos 9 menos la inicial que es
menos 7 entonces tenemos
29 - menos 7 es lo mismo que menos 9 + 7
y eso es menos 2 muy bien entonces
nuestro cambio
es menos 2 entonces si por ejemplo
quisiéramos ver la longitud de estos
segmentos en realidad lo único que
tendríamos que hacer es tomar valor
absoluto pero en realidad no importa
verdad porque vamos a tomar los números
al cuadrado así que no importa si
tomamos negativos o positivos así que
vamos ahora a sustituir tendremos que la
distancia al cuadrado será el cambio en
x al cuadrado que ya lo tenemos que es
menos 1 al cuadrado y eso es 1 y vamos a
sumar el cambio ya que es menos 2
elevado al cuadrado pero menos 2 al
cuadrado es 4 así que fácilmente podemos
ver que la distancia al cuadrado es 14
que es 5 o bien la distancia que es
esencialmente lo que nos interesa es la
raíz cuadrada
5 y por supuesto en realidad a esta
distancia podría haberle llamado radio
verdad que es justamente lo que
estábamos buscando y con esto terminamos
el ejercicio